Go into boring niches. Go into boring niches. This goes hand in hand with what I just said.
When you get into this business model, you have to get two things right.
You have to get the niche right and you have to get the city right. Okay? So
why not eliminate half the work and go into a niche that we already know works, that other
people have already made money in and are having phenomenal success in? Why not cut the workload
in half and say, hey, Nick's been talking about masonry for a while. Nick's been talking about
concrete for a while. He's made lots of money in it. It fits the bill. It works. And I'm seeing
all these other people doing it. Huh, maybe I should do that too, right? Maybe I should,
because now I don't have to worry because guys, if you go into a brand new niche,
you have no nothing about. You have to figure out if that niche even fits this business model.
That might be more of a niche you need to run Facebook ads for or you need it. It's more of
like a social, like a content niche or a Instagrammable niche, right? Pick boring niches
and eliminate half the work.